Bitte schön.
Okay, dann ja. Guten Tag.
AK ist mein Name.
Ich bin momentan der Dienstabendeerst.
Ich bin für Sie da.
Kurz zum Ablauf.
Zuerst werde ich Ihre persönliche Datum nachfragen.
Dann Ihre Beschwede.
Dann einige Informationen über Ihre Familie.
Sind Sie dann verstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich bin extra jetzt hierhergekommen.
Damit Sie mich sehen.
Man hat mir gesagt, Sie sind ein sehr guter Arzt.
Ja, danke.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Frank Schaffhausen.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, natürlich.
Schaffhausen, das ist Sieg.
Also, SCH.
Anton, 2 mal F.
Wie friedlich.
Und dann Hans, August oder Siegfried.
Ihnen dort wohl. Hausen.
Schaffhausen.
Schaffhausen, ja.
Also, wie alt sind Sie Herr Schaffhausen?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Und waren genau 90 geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 1. August 1980.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1 Meter 74.
Wie viel liegen Sie?
Also ungefähr 90 Kilo.
Ja, okay Herr Schaffhausen.
Danke für die Informationen.
Also, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was zu bestreiten haben Sie?
Also Herr Doktor, ich habe schon seit ungefähr 6 Wochen
zunehmende Luftnot.
Ich hatte vor 6 Wochen Corona-Infektion gehabt.
Und seit 3 Wochen wird diese Luftnot immer schlimmer.
Und ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass hier auf der linken Seite der Brust
das ist da sehr eng wird.
Und ich habe Beklemmungsgefühle.
Also, ist diese Schmerzen atemabhängig?
Nein, also das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Das kommt immer wieder.
Dann habe ich wieder 1, 2 Tage Ruhe.
Aber jetzt habe ich das zuletzt auch in der Nacht bekommen.
Ich kann plötzlich ganz schlecht atmen.
Ich habe so einen Druck auf der Brust.
Und wenn ich versuche, einzuatmen, dann ist es sehr schwierig.
Also sind diese Schmerzen immer da oder manchmal weg?
Aber in letzter Zeit ist es eigentlich fast immer da.
Insbesondere wenn ich mich anstrenge oder wenn ich laufe
oder wenn ich versuche zu arbeiten, dann wird es schlimmer.
Also wie ich verstanden habe, körperliche Belastung
verschlechtert ihre Bestwerden, oder?
Ja, das wird dann schlimmer.
Und gibt es etwas, dass ihre Bestwerden liendert?
Also bisher leider nicht.
Ich habe auch schon verschiedene Schmerzen, die ich habe probiert.
Aber es ist nicht besser geworden.
Ich bekomme immer mehr Angst, dass ich vielleicht ein Herzproblem bekomme.
Ich habe die Akustik nicht verstanden.
Ich habe Angst, dass das mein Herz ist.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Herr Schaffhausen, also, ja okay.
Können Sie oder haben Sie Schwellungen in Ihrem Körper bemerkt?
Zum Beispiel Schubrunggelenk oder an den Beinen besonders?
Ach so, an den Beinen, nein.
Dann habe ich keine Schwellungen.
Können Sie flach liegen oder brauchen Sie viele Kissen?
Es geht schon, als ich kann mich flach liegen.
Aber ich merke, dass es nicht lange geht.
Ich muss mich immer wieder aufrecht sitzen,
damit ich etwas besser Luft bekomme.
Bin ich mich auf der Rückkehmege, dann nach einigen Minuten
wird das mit der Luft etwas schlimmer.
Ich habe auch Schmerzen auf der Brust.
Vielleicht brauchen Sie auch Kissen?
Schönen Sie mich nicht so besser?
Ich habe es noch nicht probiert.
Aber ich sitze dann auf dem Stuhl oder auf dem Sofa.
Ja, okay.
Waren Sie in diesem Zeitraum bei einem anderen Arzt?
Wegen diesen Beschwerden, meine ich?
Ja, ich habe einen Hausarzt, aber ich habe das Gefühl,
er hat es nicht ernst genommen.
Er dachte, das kommt vielleicht von Corona,
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Es ist schon so lange her.
Ich habe nämlich etwas belesen.
Ich habe auch drin, dass man nach Corona
auch Herzbeschwerden haben kann.
Oder eine Herzmuskelentzündung.
Ich habe jetzt Angst.
Herr Schafau, ich verstehe Sie gut.
Aber zuerst sollen wir herausfinden, was das ist.
Deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Man hat mir gesagt, Sie sind ein sehr guter Arzt.
Es ist gut, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Ja, genau, Sie haben Recht.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Haben Sie noch etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Was ist your name, Heinz Blau?
An sich jetzt nicht, aber in den letzten Tagen
ist auch mein Schlaf etwas schlecht.
Ich werde immer wieder wach in der Nacht
und merke, dass ich auch
etwas Schmerzen im Rücken habe
und manchmal auch auf der linken Schulterseite.
Das geht dann wieder weg.
Aber ich war vor fünf Jahren bei einem Herzspezialistin.
Der hatte mir damals gesagt, ich habe einen Herzklappchen fegen.
Und das macht mir jetzt auch Angst, ob das vielleicht auch ein Problem ist oder ob das schlimmer geworden ist.
Erinnern Sie sich genau, wie nennt dieses Problem, wie heißt dieses Problem?
Ach so, Sie meinen welche Klappe.
Er meinte, das lassen Sie mich überlegen. Ich glaube, das war die Metralklappe. Gibt es sowas?
Ja genau.
Der meinte, die Metralklappe ist nicht schließt, nicht ganz dicht.
Und ich habe jetzt Angst, ob das vielleicht ein Problem ist.
Ich verstehe. Also, sind Sie zu Ihren Kontrollterminen für dieses Problem?
Nein, nein, danach war ich nicht mehr.
Aber ich hatte auch bis vor sechs Wochen habe ich auch keine Probleme gehabt.
Deswegen bin ich auch nicht zum Arzt.
Also, okay, Herr Schaffhausen, müssen Sie nachts Wasser lassen?
Nein.
Okay, ja. Haben Sie Fieber?
Als ich die Infektion hatte vor sechs Wochen, da habe ich Fieber gehabt für einige Tage.
Aber danach eigentlich nicht mehr. Nein.
Also, nachts, ich weiß ausbrüche oder...
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist die Akkretät?
Der ist eigentlich ganz gut, ich habe Hunger, ich esse auch gerne.
Da habe ich kein Problem.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, also mein Gewicht ist immer stabil.
Haben Sie irgendeine Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, bisher hat es immer ganz gut funktioniert.
Da habe ich glücklicherweise keine Probleme.
Schaffhausen, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich habe auch einen Booster um schon.
Im November habe ich meine dritte Impfung bekommen.
Und auch die anderen Impfungen hat mein Hausarzt gesagt, die sind vollständig.
Okay.
Also, auch die eigenen Kinderkrankheiten, sind Sie schon geimpft?
Ich weiß, ich gehe jetzt nicht im Einzelnen, aber mein Hausarzt hat die vom halben Jahr die Impfungen im Impfausweis bekommen.
Ich habe mir im Einzelnen im Einzelnen im Einzelnen im Einzelnen im Einzelnen angeguckt.
Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Ich denke, dass auch die Kinderkrankheiten damit gemeint sind.
Ja, das ist gut.
Herr Schaffhausen, leisen Sie vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte mal vor sechs Jahren mal eine Gastritis mal gehabt.
Und ich musste da auch eine Woche so Antibiotika nehmen.
Und seitdem habe ich immer wieder mal so ein bisschen Magenschmerzen, aber nicht mal so schlimm wie früher.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Andere Erkrankungen meinen Sie?
Ja.
Nein, nein.
Ansonsten habe ich keine Probleme.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie, elegantlich oder regelmäßig ein?
Also regelmäßig habe ich keine Medikamente.
Ich nehme ab und zu mal etwas für den Magel.
Das ist das Renny.
Das ist so eine Cow-Tablette.
Das hilft mir immer wieder.
Ansonsten will ich mal Schmerzen, aber so wie jetzt nehme ich ibuprofen.
Und welcher Dosier?
Auch je nachdem.
Ich glaube, gibt es 400 Millikant?
Ja.
Dann sind es die 400 Millikant.
Das kriege ich immer ohne Rezept aus der Apotheke.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass die Gegner in diese Schmerz-Tablette eingenommen.
Wann haben Sie zuletzt mal ibuprofen?
Also vor drei Tagen habe ich das mal eingenommen.
Für zwei Stück.
Das hat nichts gebracht.
Deswegen habe ich es auch wieder aufgehört.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mir meinen Blind-Tarm operiert.
Ist das alles?
Ja, das reicht doch, oder?
Sind bei Ihnen alle noch Kinder bekannt?
Bisher noch nicht.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, nicht brauchen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu, aber sehr selten.
Wie häufig?
Pro Woche, pro Monat?
Nein, vielleicht einmal im Monat.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht übel.
Die folgende Frage ist, das ist nur eine Protein.
Nehmen Sie eine Protein?
Ich habe es schon probiert.
Wenn Sie mich so direkt fragen,
muss ich ehrlich sagen, ja.
Ich war vor zehn Jahren wegen Drogensitz
auch für eine kurze Zeit in Gefängnis.
Für zwei, drei Monate.
Da hatte ich mal kurzfristig Drogen genommen,
aber seitdem nicht mehr.
Und welche Drogen genau?
Das war ein bisschen Gras, also Marijuana.
Ich hatte da auch Schwierigkeiten,
habe dann X-Tis genommen.
Also harte Drogen habe ich eigentlich nicht probiert.
Okay, das war zu letzt mal vor zehn Jahren.
Ja, das liegt schon lange zurück.
Ja, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich wohne allein.
Ich bin solo und bin alleine.
Okay, ich glaube, oder haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich?
Ja, ja.
Ich bin Ingenieur für Flugzeugtechnik.
Ja, treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, also ich versuche regelmäßig ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen.
Also einmal die Woche.
Ich mache ein bisschen Geräte, Training und Muskelaufbau.
Aber zum Beispiel in diesen letzten Wochen
haben Sie, können Sie gehen?
Nein, das stimmt.
Da hatte ich starke Schmerzen, deswegen habe ich das mal gelassen.
Da konnte ich nicht gehen.
Das stimmt.
Okay, ja.
Das habe ich auch so vermutet.
Also Herr Schafhausen, gibt es wichtige Krankheiten
in Ihren nahen Verwandtschaften?
Ich meine hier Ihre Eltern, Ihre Geschwister,
Bullethochdruck.
Ja, leider, also mein Vater hat vor fünf Jahren die Diagnose
von einem Prostatakrebs bekommen.
Er musste operiert werden und seitdem hatte er keinen Krebs mehr,
aber er hatte Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen.
Und meine Mutter hat ein Gefäßverschluss.
Sie musste an der Bauchschlagade operiert werden.
Sie haben, glaube ich, ein Stand eingesetzt.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Und sie muss jetzt einige Tablete nehmen,
aber es geht jetzt seit der Operation ganz gut.
Okay, ja.
Ich habe meine Notizen gemacht.
Herr Dr., was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Jetzt haben Sie mich die ganze Zeit gefragt,
aber ich bin ja extra zu Ihnen gekommen,
dass Sie mir helfen.
Was wollen Sie jetzt tun?
Was wollen Sie untersuchen?
Was meinen Sie?
Was ist das, was Schlimmes?
Ja, das sind Angst.
Wissen Sie, Herr Schafhausen,
unsere Untersuchungen sind noch nicht zu Ende.
Wir brauchen noch ein paar Untersuchungen.
Zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich den Volute abnehmen.
Dann, weil wir da fertig mit meinen Kollegen sprechen.
Aber nach geschädigen Angaben.
Schauen Sie auch meinen Herz noch mal an.
Ich bin ja extra deswegen gekommen.
Entschuldigung?
Schauen Sie auch meinen Herz an.
Ja, natürlich, bei der körperliche Untersuchung.
Nur eine körperliche Untersuchung?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe Angst, da war es gut.
Ja, natürlich.
Zuerst sollte ich eine KG durchführen,
vielleicht am Anfang.
Ah, okay.
Genau.
Machen Sie auch einen Ultraschall, Herr Doktor?
Ich bin ja extra zu Ihnen gekommen.
Sie sind ja ein guter Arzt, Herr Doktor.
Machen Sie auch einen Ultraschall vom Herr Doktor?
Ja, Sie haben schon erwähnt,
besonders dieses Klappenproblem.
Das sollen wir irgendwie mal überprüfen.
Wer soll das?
Ja, ich wäre Ihnen sehr dankbar, Herr Doktor.
Wir sind sicher, ich habe Angst, Herr Doktor.
Ich möchte nicht sterben, Herr Doktor.
Ja, Herr Schafhausen.
Es ist gut, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Bitte machen Sie sich keine große Sorgen.
Wir sind hier, um Ihnen zu helfen.
Sie sind in guten Händen.
Vielen Dank.
Sie haben einen sehr guten Ruf, Herr Doktor.
Ich bin extra zu Ihnen gekommen, Herr Doktor.
Bitte schauen Sie nach, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe echt große Angst, Herr Doktor.
Ja, natürlich.
Wir werden alles machen, was möglich ist.
Natürlich.
Ich möchte nicht sterben, Herr Doktor.
Ich bin noch sehr jung, Herr Doktor.
Ja, aber bitte Herr Schafhausen.
Wie kommen Sie darauf?
Ja, Herr Doktor, wissen Sie, ich habe Angst.
Die Schmerzen werden immer schlimmer.
Mein Opa hat ja mal Herz infarkt.
Da kommt es in der Familie sehr stark vor.
Ich habe Angst, dass es ein Herzproblem ist.
Ich hatte Corona.
Mein Herz klappt, ich weiß nicht.
Das macht mir alles Angst, Herr Doktor.
Ja, Sie haben Recht darüber nachzudenken, natürlich.
Schauen Sie nach meinem Herz, Herr Doktor.
Machen Sie ein Ultraschall, Herr Doktor?
Ja, natürlich.
Alle wichtigen Untersuchungen werden wir durchführen, natürlich.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Wann wollen Sie das machen, Herr Doktor?
Machen Sie das gleich?
Ja, genau.
Aber Sie sollen hier,
Sie sollen hier,
im Krankenhaus bleiben, zumindest einigestunden,
vielleicht auch in der Nacht,
ist das in der Nacht.
Muss ich wirklich bleiben, Herr Doktor?
Ich habe Angst vor dem Krankenhaus, Herr Doktor.
Jetzt in der Corona-Zeit.
Ach bitte, da sind Sie schnell, dass ich nicht bleiben muss.
Ja, nach den Untersuchungen werden wir das wieder beurteilen,
aber momentan,
ich habe Angst,
ich habe Angst vor dem Krankenhaus,
aber momentan,
sollen Sie sich unbedingt hier im Krankenhaus bleiben
für die erste Untersuchungen?
Haben Sie jemanden, der Ihnen helfen kann,
zum Beispiel Ihre Sachen hier mitbringen, oder?
Ja, meine Nachbarn ist eine ganz nette Frau.
Ich kann Sie auch anrufen, ja.
Aber ich möchte nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben, Herr Doktor.
Muss es wirklich sein,
muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben, Herr Doktor?
Diese Entscheidung werden wir laut Dein Ergebnis treffen.
Werden Sie die Entscheidung treffen?
Ich bin extra zu Ihnen gekommen, Herr Doktor.
Sie werden entscheiden, ja?
Sie werden die Entscheidung treffen?
Ja.
Ich will nicht woanders, Herr Doktor.
Ich will bei Ihnen bleiben.
Ich bin extra zu Ihnen gekommen, Herr Doktor.
Ich möchte keinen anderen Arzt.
Ich bin jetzt bei Ihnen.
Bitte untersuchen Sie mich, Herr Doktor.
Ich möchte nicht woanders gehen.
Ja, ja, ich bin für Sie ständig.
Ich schieke Ihnen zu...
nicht zu einem anderen Arzt, ja?
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Ich kümmere mich darum, ja, natürlich.
Danke, Herr Doktor.
Sie sind ein guter Mensch.
Sie sind ein sehr netter Arzt, Herr Doktor.
Weil wir da fährt,
ich werde auch mit meinem Kollegen sprechen für Sie.
Okay.
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Ich warte jetzt, ja?
Sie wollen ein Foto suchen?
Ja, natürlich.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz auf den Unterrichtstisch.
Danke, Herr Doktor.
Ömer, Herr Doktor,
hier, wie viel Geld verwendet?
Einiges, das du hier sehr gut machst.
Also,
ob ich etwas machen will?
Ich bin sehr gut,
weil ich in der letzten Zeit
die Reaktion unter mir,
die ich in der letzten Zeit gestartet habe,
die ja immer wieder mit mir gemacht haben.
Ich möchte Sie darauf sagen.
Wir haben hier sehr gut gemacht.
Herr Doktor,
ja, hier, in solchen Situationen,
sind die Scheisse, die sind sehr gut,
die sind sehr gut,
wie die Arzt.
Ich werde diese Foto suchen,
ich werde sie bitte machen,
ich werde sie auf den Blut abnehmen,
dann auch machen,
ich würde sie auf den Blut einbauen,
ich werde sie auf den Blut suchen.
Ich sage jetzt der der Krankenschweste oder der Arztzentren, sie soll ihnen jetzt Blut abnehmen und dann machen wir ein EKG und anschließend werden wir ein Ultraschall von Herzen machen und danach sehen wir weiter.
Sie werden hier überwacht, es ist immer eine Krankenschwester da, ich bin auch da, sie können sich jederzeit merken, wenn sie Schmerzen haben, den nebieren.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patient vorstellen, haben Sie kurz Zeit?
Ah Herr Kollege, grüß Gott, schön, dass Sie da sind, freut mich. Natürlich, Sie habe ich immer Zeit Herr Kollege, bitte schön, was haben Sie?
Herr Frank Schaffhausen, ein 52-jähriger Patient.
42, 42, 52 die, 42.
Ah ok, dann, 1,74 Meter groß und 90 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Schaffhausen klagt über seit 6 Wochen bestehende Dispne und eine drückende trockale Schmerzen in der linken Seite.
Im Laufe der Zeit seien die Beschwerden präkreditierend.
Ja, die körperliche Belastung verwertet der Patient aus einem exa-Bier-Extra-Faktor.
Den Begriff der Exa-Zerpation benutzt man eher bei der Lunge oder zur OPD.
Aber ok, ich würde Ihnen lieber sagen, er hat eine belastende Situation oder bei Belastung zunehmende Schmerzen.
Zunehmende Schmerzen, ja ok.
Gegen die Schmerzen hat er Ibuprofen eingenommen, aber das hat ihn nicht geholfen.
Bei dem Patient, initial war die Sufizienz bekannt.
Die hochgradigste Insuffizienz, wissen Sie das?
Ja, in diesem Zusammenhang war er nicht unter Kontrolle.
Eine ästliche Folge hat er nicht in diesem Zusammenhang.
Was haben Sie bei der Hauskultation gehört?
Hört mal eine Metralinsuffizienz, wenn Sie abhorchen.
Ja, natürlich. Man hört, was das war, eine Nebengröße.
Ich wollte wissen, ob das eine hochgradige Metral-Klappeninsuffizienz ist.
Das hört man bei der Auskultation.
Aber dann hat er auch sicherlich unterschiedliche Ideen.
Das hat er natürlich.
Hat er Ideen?
Ideen wurde verneint.
Nehmt er Medikamente? Nehmt er Diuretika?
Nein, nehmt er...
Das heißt, dann ist die Metral-Klappeninsuffizienz nicht so hochgradig.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ok, dann werden wir nochmal mit dem Ultraschall, mit dem Echonome nachschauen.
Das machen Sie nach.
Dann erwarten wir...
Nein, ich meine Sie schauen mit dem Herz Ultraschall ja nochmal nach seinem Herz.
Ja, natürlich.
Wir machen eine Echokadographie.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, oder?
Dann können Sie die Metral-Klappen noch einmal beurteilen.
Vielleicht, dass es sehr tragisch ist.
Erst mal ein Echo.
Erst mal Echo und dann sehen wir weiter.
Ok, sehr gut.
Und übrigens meldet sie über Insomnia.
Ja.
Die übrige vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Vor sechs Wochen hat der Patient Covid.
Ah, ok. Begeht es ihm jetzt?
Er berichtet, dass nach der Erbesserung geht es ihm nicht gut,
eigentlich die Beschwerden nehmen im Laufe der Zeit zu.
Welche Beschwerden?
Diese Linkstorokran-Schmerzen, oder?
Dyspenö.
Dyspenö, ok.
Ja.
Hat er noch Husten, oder?
Ja, danach habe ich nicht gefragt, aber das mache ich bei der Keilischen.
Der Patient hat keine Husten.
Ja.
Ok.
Anvor Erkrankungen leidet er an Gastritis.
Dagegen nimmt er Sennitabletten, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Ah, ok.
Und an Medikamenten nimmt er noch Bio-Bio-Profen 400 mg.
Bei den Patienten erfolgt eine Appendoktermie im Kindesalter.
Bei ihm keine Allerginbekannt, sind keine Allerginbekannt.
Er ist nicht traurig, er trinkt elegantisch 1 oder 2 Mal Promenalkohol.
Er trinke?
Ja.
Ok.
Momentan nimmt er keine Drogen, nehme er keine Drogen, aber bis 10 Jahren hat er Drogen eingenommen, Malihuana und Ecstasy.
Ist 14 Jahre, bis 14 Jahre.
Ist 14 Jahre.
Ah, ja, ok.
Er ist ledig, hat keine Kinder und Ingenieur von Beruf, treibt elegantlich Sport, nämlich Fitness.
Er macht Fitness.
Mhm, ok.
In der Familienanalyse hat er angegeben, dass sein Vater an Prostatakarsinom gelitten, aber der Vater lebt doch, er ist am Leben.
Mhm.
Und die Mutter hatte einen Stanz, für Autos.
Ah, ok. Also sie hat eine AVK, eine arteriehrende Stinnose, eine Ortenstinnose.
Ok.
Ah, ok. Das habe ich nicht gut fest, andere Autos.
Also, ich sehe, Herr Oberarzt, ja, meine Verdachtsdiagnose ist endokarditis.
Mhm, wieso? Hatte Fieber?
Eigentlich, ja, er hat kein Fieber, aber diese, wie soll man, Metrolwaldeninsuffizienz, moment.
Sie denken, warum denken Sie, dass er jetzt eine endokarditis hat?
Ja, wegen dieser Diagnose, trockale Schmerzen und aufruhend liegende Metrolwaldeninsuffizienz.
Ok, also das ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose.
Was kann es noch sein, was ist noch für Differenzdiagnose?
Wir können nachdem einzeln, wir können kurz mal durchsprechen, wie er die Diagnose ist.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen im Betracht Lungenembolie.
Ok, wegen der Luftwurz, ja, was ist noch?
Coronasyndrom, kann auch sein.
Ah, Sie denken, eine Coronasyndrom, ok.
Dann vielleicht auch ein Pluralitis.
Ja, die Frage ist warum, ok, ja, was noch?
Eigentlich, die Schmerzen ist nicht abhängig von Atmung, aber ja.
Ok, haben Sie weitere Ideen, woran man denken muss, bei März, Druck und Luftnot?
Neumotorax vielleicht, kann sein, oder?
Ja, so einen spontanen Pneumotorax, muss man immer denken, ja.
Truggefühl auf Erbos.
Was meinen die anderen Kollegen?
Wegen der Impfung? Nein.
Der hatte ja nur eine Chorinfektion, der hatte zweimal vor der Impfung gehabt.
Was soll wegen der Impfung sein?
Etwas genauer formulieren.
Ok, also Endocarditis, pericarditis, ja, warum?
Plural Ergust.
Ein Plural Ergust, ja.
Herzinsurizenz, der unwahrscheinlich mal keine Idee hat.
Ok, also Sie müssen auch immer an die ganz einfachen Sachen denken, nicht immer sehr kompliziert.
Es gibt ein Sprichdorf, das heißt, was viel ist viel, was wenig ist, ist wenig.
Das heißt, man muss auch eine ganz banale, einfache Erkrankung auch mal denken.
Zum Beispiel, wo man denken sieht.
Neocarditis.
Sie denken als Kardiologe natürlich an Neocarditis,
die Prostinfektion ist nach einer Corona-Infektion.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, genau.
Keine Fieber.
Kein Fieber, genau.
Sie sind der Kardiologe, Herr Doktor.
Meinen Sie, es kann eine Endocarditis sein?
Nein, weil die Pferenzial Diabös wahrscheinlich schreiben,
aber keine Fieber und keine andere Insifizielles Symptome ödeme.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, genau.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit für eine Endocarditis ist eigentlich sehr gering.
Normalerweise sind die Krankheitssymptome bei einer Endocarditis sehr schwerwiegend.
Wie bei dyspne, schweres Krankheitsgefühl und so weiter.
Also das ist hier nicht der Fall.
Aber Myocarditis ist eher wahrscheinlich, weil er hat Covid-Infektion gehabt.
Nach einer Virusinfektion, egal nach einer Influencer oder andere,
ist eine Wahrscheinlich da, dass eine Myocarditis auch bei jungen Menschen auftreten kann.
Genau.
Aber jetzt noch mal die Frage,
woran denken Sie bei ganz einfachen Erkrankungen oder alltäglichen,
was fast jeder hat?
An so etwas müssen Sie denken.
Jetzt muss nicht immer etwas ganz Schlimmes sein.
Lungenöden.
Bitte?
Ja, aber ja, Lungenöden, was noch?
Typik Pneumonie.
Pneumonie, genau.
Brunchitis.
Ich denke jetzt an den Rücken.
Da hat der Schmerzen, links Toracicard.
Was kann da sein, was viele Menschen haben?
Ganz einfach.
Anginapektoris.
Bitte?
Ja, das haben wir schon gesagt.
Das ist ein gutes Synchro.
Ich denke an den Rücken.
An den Rücken, was wir da denken.
Bruce Lee, wir gehen mit dem Synchro.
Ein BWS-Syndrom, ganz einfach.
Das sind Muskelverspannungen meistens.
Der ist sehr verspannt.
Und die können natürlich ausstrahlen,
im Sinne einer interkostalen Neurohavie zum Beispiel.
Haben sehr viele Menschen durch langesitzen,
durch Arbeit, durch Belastung, durch Sport, durch eine Erkältung.
Das hat fast jeder.
Also auch an solche einfachen Sachen denken.
Genau, auf mehr Allgien muss geschmerzen.
Also, dann verrate ich mal, das war auch ein Patient,
der ist heute zu mir gekommen.
Ein junger Mann.
Und hat wirklich Angst, so wie ich das vorgestellt habe.
Und ist extra wirklich zu mir gekommen,
weil ich Kardäologe war,
weil er denkt, er dachte, das ist das Herz.
Ich habe ihn natürlich so wie sie genau anemonstriziert.
Und dann habe ich ihn untersucht.
Wir haben als erstes gleich ein EKG gemacht.
Das war aber unauffällig.
Ein normaler Synus-Rhythmus.
Herzfrequenz von ca. 72 pro Minute.
Ein Linkslagetyp.
Die QR-Komplexe und P-Welle, T-Welle.
Alles völlig unauffällig.
Also keine Hinweise für Herz-Rhythmus-Störungen
oder für eine Ischemia oder KHK.
Also ein normales EKG, ein unauffälliges EKG.
Punkt.
Dann hatte er einen normalen Blutdruck,
also einen normalen Blutdruck von 120 bis 70 gehabt.
Das war auch da völlig unauffällig.
Ich habe ihn abgehört.
Er ist pulmonal.
Er hat eine pulmonale Atemgeräusche
über alle Lungensegmente gehabt.
Das Herz war unauffällig.
Die Herztöne waren rein und rhythmisch.
Das heißt, ich habe keine Herzgeräusche gehört.
Ich habe keinen mit klappen Insuffizienz gehört.
Ich habe keine Outen, klappen Stenose
oder keine Outen Insuffizienz gehört.
Also auch unauffällig.
Er war sehr verängstigt.
Das war so ein bisschen seine Sorge.
Ich habe ihn körperlich untersucht.
Das heißt, ich habe ihn auf den Muskeln gedrückt,
Nacken, Schulter und am Brücken.
Er war hier auf der linken Seite extrem verspannt.
Ich habe ihn nur ganz leicht gedrückt.
Dann hatte er sehr starke Schmerzen angegeben.
Er hat auf den Muskel spektral gedrückt.
Er hatte starke Schmerzen.
Ich habe ihn auf die Rippen gedrückt.
Er hatte starke Schmerzen angegeben.
Ich habe ihn im Bereich der BWS,
Paravertebrale auf der linken Seite.
Der Muskel war einzeln eingedrückt.
Da hatte er wahnsinnige Schmerzen.
Auf der rechten Seite war das Kast unauffällig.
Ich hatte meine Diagnose.
Für mich war das ein BWS-Syndrom.
Ganz einfach.
Ich habe natürlich auch ein Herzultraschall gemacht.
Der Herzultraschall war auch unauffällig.
Normale Herzpumpleistung.
Gute, linksventikuläre Funktion.
Er hatte eine minimale Farbduplex zu erkennen.
Er hatte eine minimalen Jet über die Metraglappe.
Das hat keine hemodynamische Relevanz.
Das war ohne Beeinträchtigung des Herzens.
Die Herzhöhlen waren normal groß.
Er hatte keine Rechtsherzbelastung.
Er hatte auch eine Trigospitalklappe.
Er hatte keine Pericardergus.
Die Muskulatur des lebten Herzens
war relativ normal.
Für mich war das eine Diagnose.
Ich sage, er war ein junger Mann.
Er war verspannt.
Ich habe eine Physiotherapie verordnet.
Bei Bedarf schmerzen Medikamente.
Mit Magenschutz.
Die Blutewerte waren auch unauffällig.
Ich habe zu viel geredet.
Ich habe alles sehr deutlich gemacht.
Herr Doktor, Sie waren sehr gut.
Ich habe sie in die Enge getrieben.
Aber Sie haben es gut gemeistert.
Am Schluss hätten Sie vielleicht noch mal auf die Patientin eingehen können.
Wir machen sofort mit erster, zweiter Schritt.
Aber das war alles sehr gut.
Ihre Aussprache, Ihre Grammatik ist auch sehr gut.
Ich denke, es war gut.
Ich denke, es wird sehr gut klappen mit der Prüfung.
Danke, hoffentlich.
Wann ist Ihre Prüfung?
Am 19. Februar.
Nächste Woche.
Wo sind Sie?
Im Stuttgart.
Im Stuttgart Zentrum.
Ja, in der Nähe.